[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar guardians of your science ask
the expert series essay design tools to
support your success
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker ben
avery field application scientist north
carolina and virginia real-time pcr and
digital pcr thermo fisher scientific
then you may now begin your presentation
hello everyone thank you for joining
today's webinar
entitled assay design tools to support
your success i'm hoping to cover a lot
of content today that you'll find really
beneficial to
um you know ensure successful assay
design in your lab
some of that content will be the vast
catalog of pre-designed taqman assays
that thermo fisher offers
in addition our custom assay design tool
which is a really beneficial tool that
you can use through the web browser to
order custom design taxman assays for
work in your laboratory as well as
ordering individual oligos we're going
to go through several case studies
potential case study scenarios where
each of those tools may be beneficial to
you
in addition
i'll present content in the slides today
as well i'll i'll move away from the
slides and navigate through thermo
fisher's website which because
thermofish are such a large organization
the website can be challenging to
navigate at times with all the products
from my fisher sales so i want to make
sure you're able to navigate the website
efficiently as possible and find the
products you need
with that i'll start the presentation
my plan for this webinar was to
hopefully present some content that's
beneficial to a wide range of scientists
researchers laboratories so some of the
individual scientists or laboratories
that may find this content useful are
labs that are considering using taqman
chemistry maybe you're a cyber green
user you've never used pacman chemistry
and you're considering transitioning all
your cyber green assays to taqman assays
maybe you're a researcher that's
committed to using site committed using
taqman chemistry but you're just
inexperienced with designing probe based
assay so you want some additional
support designing your probe based
assays
maybe you've searched for a pre-designed
assay within our vast catalog of
pre-designed tacman assays and can't
find what you're looking for because the
research you're doing is in a species or
organism that isn't typically researched
or you're looking at a gene target that
isn't a commonly researched gene target
maybe you have a really aggressive
timeline and you need a cookie cutter
answer or a really quick um solution for
the technical problem you're addressing
so you need to get the materials for
assay design to your lab as quickly as
possible
maybe your laboratory is very
experienced with assay design but you're
interested in simplifying your workflow
so that you can move from r d into a
production environment
or maybe your laboratory is extremely
comfortable with assay design but you
want to screen multiple primers and
probes you want to screen multiple
oligos for finding the best design best
combinations of primers and probes
possible to implement into your
laboratory's workflow so hopefully the
content
in this presentation will benefit all
those potential customers
before we jump into the meat of the
presentation and navigate the thermo
fisher website to find these different
products and find these different tools
i think it would be wise for us to just
have a brief level set on what is tacman
chemistry and how tacman chemistry works
so to fully understand taqman chemistry
is important to understand the concept
of fret fret stands for fluorescence
resonance energy transfer and in this
image over here on the left-hand side of
the screen
you see an intact tacman probe in an
intact tacman probe the reporter
molecule which is this green molecule
here is going to be in close proximity
to the quencher molecule the quencher
molecule is this red molecule here
this gold connection between the
reporter and the quencher that would be
your 20 to 30 base sequence specific
oligarch
whenever the reporter and quencher are
in their intact confirmation meaning
that the reporter and quentra are in
proximity to each other when light from
the excitation source on your real-time
pcr instrument whether it be a halogen
lamp led argon laser whenever that
excitation source strikes the reporter
die and excites the reporter die energy
will be transferred from the reporter to
the quencher so that no fluorescence
signal is emitted and this will be the
case as long as the probe is in its
intact conformation
at any point the probe is split or
pleased as is shown in the image here on
the right
when the
um light from the excitation source and
your real-time pcr instrument strikes
the reporter die it can no longer
participate in fret it can no longer
transfer that energy to the quencher
molecule so a fluorescent signal will be
emitted
to zoom out just a bit and look at how
this works in the context of a real-time
pcr reaction for real-time pcr reaction
you always start with some sort of
template nucleic acid whether it be dna
or cdna
you'll start your pcr at high
temperature so that you denature your
nucleic acid so it's double stranded or
excuse me single stranded as shown here
at high temperature at 95 degrees your
primers shown here and here will not
have yet annealed your probe also will
not have yet annealed
the temperature will begin to decrease
and as the temperature drops down your
primers shown here and probe will anneal
the probe will anneal first at around 70
degrees
the primers will anneal second at around
60 degrees
once the primers and probe have annealed
during the extension phase of pcr the
attack polymerase shown here will find
the three prime o h of those primers and
begin extending off of the three prime o
h of those primers
the attack in addition to having
polymerase activity also has five prime
nuclease activity so the attack has no
issue no problem i'm chewing up um and
digesting the probe that's been bound to
the temple nucleic acid sequence once
the attack has digested that probe the
quencher and reporter will no longer be
in proximity to each other and a
fluorescent signal will be emitted by
the reporter die the fluorescent signal
will be captured and measured by your
real-time pcr instrument as shown here
so when we discuss tacman probes it's
important to understand that there's a
few different types of tacman probes
available for use
so the top tacman probe here shown here
is what's referred to as a tamara probe
the quencher molecule for tamara probes
is a fluorescent molecule um called
tamara
tamara even though it fluoresces it can
still participate in fret and receive
energy from the reporter molecule
um these camera probes are a bit of an
older technology and they're what are
also referred to as long probes so as
mentioned on the previous slide it's
important for the probe to have an
annealing temperature 10 degrees higher
higher than the primers and the most
straightforward kind of most classical
way of doing that would be to have the
probe be longer than the primers so
these tamara probes were generally
speaking long probes there's a slight
disadvantage to using long probes the
disadvantage of using long probes is
that they're just less specific less
discriminatory than shorter probes so if
you imagine a situation where you're
looking to identify
you know a single base substitution
potentially in like a somatic variant
this tamara probe may anneal even in the
presence of a single base mismatch in
the nucleic acid sequence so just know
that tamara probes are long probes long
probes are just less specific than
shorter probes
another type of probe that is more
commonly used
currently is what's referred to as an
nfq mgb probe nfq mgb probes have a
non-fluorescent quantum molecule on the
three prime end of the probe the nf2
stands for non-fluorescent quencher and
in addition there's an mgb or a minor
groove binder this minor groove binder
is bound to the non-fluorescent quencher
and the minor groove binder serves to
increase the annealing temperature
higher than it otherwise would be based
on the length of the probe
the advantage of increasing that
annealing temperature is that you can
design a shorter probe without having to
sacrifice a kneeling temperature and the
advantage of having that shorter probe
is that it's going to be more specific
so in contrast to the tamra probes these
nfq mgb probes are much shorter more
specific and less likely to be tolerant
of a single base mismatch
and then lastly a third type of probe
that is available is what's referred to
as a qsy probe
these qsy probes have a qsy quencher the
qsy quencher is also a non-fluorescent
quencher and these probes are extremely
useful if you're choosing to multiplex
more than two targets if you're choosing
to multiplex more than two targets
within a given reaction there's a strong
recommendation to only have
up to two nfq mgb probes within that
reaction these nfq mgb probes have a
difficult time quenching the
more red dyes such as abby or june
whereas the qsy quencher is much better
at um quenching the abby and june dice
so if you do want to do a multiplex with
three or more targets including abby and
june the qsy quencher is the best option
for you
one more thing i think we should just
briefly level set on is a little bit of
content around the the nomenclature of
tacman assays
so if you hear me or anyone else within
the thermoefficient organization refer
to the um takman probes what we're
talking about is a single oligo that has
a five prime reporter die and a three
prime quencher so taqman probes are just
the probe just that single oligo if you
hear anyone speak of pacman assays
taqman assays are the combination of
that single probe oliga with the five
prime reporter and three prime quencher
and in addition there's a forward primer
and a reverse primer in either single
tube format or some other format so i
hear a lot of people refer to taqman
assays as taqman probes so i think it's
an important distinction to make um the
taqman probes are in fact a single oligo
whereas taqman assays are referring to
at least three oligos a forward primer
reverse primer and a probe this is an
important distinction because when
talking about assay design the design of
the primers can sometimes be just as
important as the design of the probes
when we talk about taqman assays in
terms of um
there's two broad categories that are
worth mentioning one of which would be
gene expression assays and gene
expression assays are what i just
described where in the single tube
format there would be a single forward
primer a single reverse primer and a
single probe oligo with that five prime
reporter die and three prime quencher
die another type or
application of tacman assays would be
genotyping assays in genotyping assays
there is a forward primer a reverse
primer and then two different sequence
specific oligos those two different
sequence specific oligos will target
specific alleles
those two sequence specific probes will
have different five prime reporter dies
on them almost always sam and vic so
that you can do genotyping within your
lab and then one last bit of
nomenclature just to kind of speak of
when we discuss pre-designed taqman
assays um these are essentially
synonymous with like off-the-shelf
tachman assays so thermo fisher has a
large catalog over 21 million
pre-designed taqman assays of which
therma fisher has done the design and
unowns the designs
the other option for purchasing kakman
assays is to purchase custom taqman
assays if we're speaking about custom
taqman assays there's a couple of
different different avenues to pursue
there you can purchase a custom taqman
assay
where you have done the design work
yourself so you can submit your ford
primer reverse primer and probe designs
and thermo fisher can synthesize a
custom tacman assay with your specific
designs you can additionally submit a
fragment and thermo fisher will do the
design work for you and you'll get
received a custom assay of ford primer
reverse primer and probe but thermo
fisher has done the design work for you
so both of those would encompass custom
taqman assays whereas the pre-designed
or off-the-shelf taqman assays are the
ones in which thermo fisher has the
design
so in addition to those custom and
pre-designed taqman assay options for
customers um
the tacman assays can be ordered in
multiple different formats so one of the
most commonly ordered formats is the
single tube assay so these single tube
assays are just what they sound like
you'll receive a single tube shipped to
your lab that will contain the forward
primer reverse primer and probe within
that tube these single tube assays are
commonly shipped at a 20x concentration
so that it's doing a 20 microliter qpcr
reaction you just have to add one
microliter of this single tube assay to
each of your reactions and the single
tube assays can be purchased in volumes
from as low as 75 microliters or 75
reactions i should say up till 2 900
reactions
if you're going to transition from
the single tube assay format to more of
a production operation a these
pre-spotted plates referred to as tacman
array plates
those would be the um same pre-designed
or custom taqman assays that we briefly
discussed on the previous slide but
they're going to be lyophilized in
either a 96 well or 384 well plate
format this allows for
you know higher throughput in your lab
ease of execution within the lab i'm
really useful for production environment
but because
of the the configuration of these 96 or
384 well um tacmanta ray plates you
don't lose the flexibility to test any
specific number of targets any specific
number of genes of interest that you're
interested in
another option would be our 384 well
pac-man array cards shown here with
these pacman array cards there are eight
still ports and each of those eight fill
ports will then fill
um 48 different pre-spotted assays so
these are extremely useful option if you
have
a large number of targets to interrogate
a limited volume of sample with which to
work because each of these reactions on
this um pacman rate card will be an
extremely low volume reaction um but you
do lose some of the flexibility if that
you would have with these 96 or 384 well
pre-spotted tacman plates shown here and
then lastly our tacman assays as well as
custom assays can be ordered in the open
array plate format
so the open array format
can be run on our quant studio 12 k
instruments
the plate shown here has what's referred
to as 48 sub arrays each of those 48
subarrays has 64 through holes and each
of those through holes is spotted with
either a pre-designed assay or a custom
assay so you can run up to 48 samples
with up to 64 different targets on this
specific plate
within one experiment on the quant
studio 12k you can place four of these
plates on the instruments so you can do
up to 12 000 reactions on the quant
studio 12k at a time which kind of led
to its name of the quantity oh 12k
and so now that we've kind of level set
on what tacman chemistry is some of the
nomenclature pac-man chemistry the
different types of probes different
formats you can order assays um in which
you can order assays let's jump into the
meat of this presentation um in the
content that i think will be really
useful to the listeners
so our pre-designed taqman assays as
mentioned we have over 20 20 million
pre-designed tac-man assays available
they cover numerous different species of
organism
more than 35 different species of
organism and as shown here on the right
there are assays designed for various
different applications
when searching these assays online
you can filter them based on numerous
different
filtering or sorting criteria that i'm
going to demo in just a second
i mean one thing that's important to
know about these pre-designed taqman
assays is that the primer and probe
sequences of these pre-designed assays
will not be disclosed if you purchase
any of these off-the-shelf assays
however even though you won't receive
the primer and probe sequences you'll
receive a general context sequence
something that's referred to as a padded
amplicon sequence which will give you a
pretty good idea of where the
the primers and probe are annealing to
to the transcript or to the genome um
and it'll give you the amplicon context
sequence within that padded amplicon
sequence
so let's look at case study one here so
case study one reads a researcher is
studying programmed cell death ligand
one so pdl1 studying the expression
levels in non-small cell lung cancer
this researcher has no experience
designing probe-based qpcr assays and
has an aggressive timeline for
completing this project so given case
study one um because the species of
interest of here is human because pdl1
is a pretty well studied biomarker i
would be pretty confident there's a
predesigned assay available in thermo
fisher's catalog that would meet this
researcher's needs so i'm going to
navigate away from the slides for just a
second
and go to thermofisher's website
and now that we're on the thermofisher
website
let's say we want to search for that
pdl1 assay that we're interested in so
from this drop down menu here on the
left just going to select tacman assays
and within the search bar you just type
in the name of your gene of interest so
i'm going to type in pdl1
and hit enter
so as you can see there were 245
hits or results for assays and arrays so
29 of those results are gene expression
assays
188 of those results are snip genotyping
assays and 28 results are copy number
assays because case study 1 said the
researcher was interested in expression
levels let's take a look at these 29
gene expression essays
so now that i'm on this screen
our goal would be to narrow down these
29 pdo-1 assays to the
one or ones or multiple assays that are
most beneficial
to the researcher so the first filter
and your filters are shown here across
the top where it says filter your
results the first filter i would always
use would be species and so because we
know we're looking at non-small cell
lung cancer in human specimens we'll
select human
and that's going to filter us from 29
down to 8 results
so let's look at some of the other
filter options we have
so the we'll start from the bottom up so
this bottom filter says does not detect
genomic dna so if the researcher really
wants to truly only amplify mrna if they
truly want to only amplify the
transcripts and not have the primers and
probes anneal to genomic dna which is
likely the case they could select this
filter
and now we're going to go from eight
results down to six results so we
filtered out two
this next filter up says three prime
most so because rna degrades from three
prime to five prime some researchers may
want to confirm that they're amplifying
intact transcripts as opposed to just um
fragments of transcripts that may be
remaining so if that was of interest to
the researcher you could select this
filter here
um the next filter up is inventory
inventory means that this specific assay
is on the shelf and ready and in stock
and able to be shipped to a customer you
know right away and so because this
researcher mentioned that they have a
really aggressive timeline let's filter
this by only inventory database
and so we've now narrowed it down to
four results and so the last filter here
under this assay attributes drop down of
filters is best coverage best coverage
means
this particular assay will cover the
most different
rna isoforms most different known splice
variants for this specific transcript
another way to kind of say that is of
the transcripts in the refseq database
this assay will anneal and align with
the most
refseq entries in in the refseq database
so let's select best coverage here
and now we've narrowed it down to one
assay so i'll just point out a couple of
other filters but we don't need to
narrow down our results any further so
this assay design filter can be really
useful so a lot of times if you want to
detect mrna you want your probe to span
an exon exon junction so you can specify
that under this assay design filter
you may want your primers and probes
within a single exon if that's the
situation you can specify that under
this assay design filter
in a situation where you're working with
like a transgenic model and you want to
ensure that your assay is not going to
cross react with some other species this
cross reactivity drop down you can
select different species and this will
confirm that our human assay here is not
going to cross react with the species
that we may or may not select here
but since we've got it narrowed down to
one result we feel good about this assay
um the first thing i'll point out about
this tacman assay that is shown here is
this assay id so assay ids are an
alphanumeric identifier that all
pre-designed taqman assays will have
um there's always going to be a prefix
that is two letters
that prefix that as two letters tells
you the species of interest for the
assay so this hs stands for homo sapien
the suffix will always be there the
suffix tells you a little bit about the
design of the assay so this m1 suffix
means that the probe is spanning an exon
exxon junction so it's useful to have
that information about the design of the
assay and then this numeric sequence
between the prefix and the suffix
describes the target of interest and
where on the target of interest this
specific assay will will anneal but this
numeric sequence between the prefix
prefix and suffix isn't really of use to
the end user or the customer
a couple other things worth pointing out
here
um this specific assay can be ordered
both
with a fam image with a fam reporter die
and an mgb
or with a vic reporter die and an mgb
and so notice as i change from vic back
to sam this catalog number will change
but the assay id will not change
and so the catalog number shown here
corresponds to the specific die being
used in the assay and the volume of the
assay that's being purchased so these
are essentially shell catalog numbers
which will apply to any specific assay
id so to be able to purchase an
off-the-shelf taqman assay you need to
know both the assay id you want to
purchase as well as the catalog number
just with this catalog number
corresponding to the die and the size of
the assay that you want to purchase and
so for this sam mgb
um essay that the researcher may
purchase you can see you can purchase
from as few as 75 reactions up to 2900
reactions
a couple of other things worth pointing
out on this screen
is if i were to view the assay map
it will display the
gene or transcripts and what is
highlighted here in green and red
is showing the assay that we've selected
and so it shows where on the genome this
particular assay will anneal so if for
some reason this assay doesn't work well
let's say we want an additional assay
and you want the assay to be you know
just a little bit
a little bit more three prime of where
this specific assay anneals you can jump
to the very next assay and so this is a
different pdl1 assay which you can see
it will span a different exon exon
junction as opposed to the one we've got
selected here so you can see there are
various taqman assays available covering
a broad range of this pdl1 gene
so the next thing i'll point out
within this screen is you can see
there's a publication down here anytime
you perform a search for a taqman assay
and the specific taqman assay that you
found has been used and cited in a
publication and you can see this assay
id is present right here within this
publication as well as several other
assay ids
you'll have a link on this page to the
publication so it's really useful to see
what other researchers are doing with
the same assay that you may or may not
purchase so you can learn a lot about
what other researchers have done with
this specific essay
and then kind of lastly on this screen i
was hoping to show you if you were to
select this view details button
it will give you some additional
information and give you some links to
the refseq database so if i were to
select this refseq link right here
it will navigate to the refseq database
and you can scroll down to the
bottom of the link
where it has the sequence for the
transcript
then if we'll jump back to the assay
page
it's telling us that the amplicon that's
going to be generated by this assay is
going to be 77 um base pairs long
and the assay location is location 503
and so if we jump back to refseq and
find location 503
so location 503 would be right here
you know that the probe is going to
anneal within this location you don't
necessarily know if it's the front of
the probe back of the probe or the
middle probe but the probe will anneal
to location 503
and since we know that we're going to
generate a 77 base pair long amplicon
you can go 77 bases upstream 77 bases
downstream and you're going to generate
a
sequence or context sequence it's going
to be 154 bases in length and that's
what is referred to as a padded amplicon
sequence so that padded amplicon
sequence will contain
the annealing point of your primers and
probe it'll contain your true amplicon
sequence generated by this assay but it
will but you will not get the exact
primer improved sequences
so all of that information can be
obtained um just publicly from these
taqman assays um without the primary
probe sequences being given to a
customer that were to purchase this
essay
so if i navigate back to the
presentation quickly
i think case study one has been pretty
well addressed so this researcher should
be able to find that pdl1 assay on the
thermofisher website
since it's an inventory assay it should
be able to be received pretty quickly
and they should be able to get moving on
their project right away
and so let's imagine for a second that
we were not able to find an assay that
worked for us within the thermo fisher
catalog of assay so let's say
we're doing research on a species that
isn't commonly researched
if you weren't able to search within the
thermo fisher website and find a
pre-designed assay that works for you
our custom assay design tool will be a
really nice option for you to use so to
use our custom assay design tool
customer we need to either paste in or
type in a fragment sequence that's
between 61 and 5 000 nucleotides long
um the customer will then have the
ability to specify a location within
that sequence that they would like
targeted for the assay design
if that's something they need so if
you're pasting in a fragment sequence
that has a specific exon exon junction
already baked into the sequence you're
you're pasting in you can um indicate
you want to design around a specific
location in that sequence
if you don't have a specific location
you'd like the assay designed around you
can just select any and the algorithm
will design the assay to the best
possible spot within the fragment that's
been pasted in
once the um once the online tool has
generated a design for you you'll
receive an email indicating that your
custom assay design has been generated
and that custom assay design will have
its own specific assay id so similarly
to the assay id shown i'm on the website
previously if you design a custom assay
for yourself you'll receive a custom
assay id that corresponds to your
specific assay id which allows you to
order that custom assay and then you
know when you run out of material it
makes for ease of use for reordering
that assay because you already have a
custom asset id
and so one good thing to know about
these custom assays is you will be able
to receive the primer and probe
sequences for your custom assay in most
all circumstances and i'll show you
exactly when you will and will not be
able to receive those primary probe
sequences when we navigate back to the
website
so let's jump to case study too so in
case study two
a researcher is studying the expression
of heat shock proteins in sea turtles
the researchers have been using applied
biosystems cyber green chemistry but
would like to transition to tacman
chemistry so they can potentially
multiplex in the future
this researcher has never designed a
probe based assay before
so for this specific case study
um the first thing i may do
and we'll just kind of navigate back to
the main thermo fisher splash page or
the thermo fisher home page so the first
thing i might do would be to just do a
search of tacman assays so i'm going to
select tacman assays
heat shock protein
the target of interest for this
researcher
and so
typing in hsp up there we get a lot of
results
i'm again going to search the gene
expression assays
i'm going to filter by species
and you can see there are actually a lot
of different
species of both plants and animals here
for you know
that for that would be helpful to
researchers however sea turtle which is
what this one specific researcher said
he was interested in is not present here
so we're not going to be able to find a
pre-designed assay for this specific
researcher
so we need to use our custom assay
design tool so just navigating back to
the thermo fisher home page to find the
custom assay design tool you can
navigate to this button up here that
says popular
and then from there navigate to where it
says taqman realtime pcr assays
from this screen what you want to do is
just launch the custom assay design tool
which is what this button indicates
right here
and now within the custom assay design
tool you can see there are two kind of
main buttons here one for ordering
genotyping assays one for ordering gene
expression assays
this specific researcher asked about
ordering gene expression assays so we
will click here
the first thing the first question
you'll be asked when ordering this
custom taqman assay is what is your
species of interest and so you can
choose from one of the species listed
here if you like if your species is not
listed just select not listed here
then it will ask if you would like
bioinformatic analysis done
if you select no here then no
bioinformatics analysis will be done and
you will receive the primer and probe
sequences for your taqman assay
if you select yes here a proprietary
bioinformatic algorithm will be used to
make sure that the sequence you're
interested in aligns with known
transcripts for your species of interest
and it'll assess the specificity of the
designs against known transcripts of
your species of interest so if you
select not listed here then this
bioinformatics cannot be done one thing
one important thing to know about if you
select yes here for bioinformatics you
select yes here because it is a
proprietary algorithm to run that
bioinformatics you will not receive the
primer and probe sequences so what i see
a lot of customers do is you know either
select not listed here or select their
species of interest in this presence and
then just select no they don't want any
bioinformatics done
after you've made these two designations
you'll see this screen appear
and from this screen the first thing you
want to do is give your
custom assay
a name so let's say what we're looking
at heat shock protein
let's call it assay 1 for heat shock
protein
you're going to want to then either type
in or paste in a sequence that is
between 61 and 5 000 nucleotides in
length
and so we can
briefly type in a sequence there
and then you're asked if you would like
to permanently hide your primer and
probe sequences if you want to receive
the primer and probe sequences if you
don't want them hidden in the
documentation you'll receive with this
assay make sure you select no here then
you can
click check format
it will check the formatting of what's
been pasted here and check the
formatting of your naming convention
here so it says valid so my formatting
is valid and then from there you're
given the option of manually assigning a
location for the assay to target so you
can manually type in hey i want it to
target position 35 in this fragment or
if you don't have a specific position
you want targeted you can select
automatic
and the assay will target whatever the
most
whatever the best location is for
designing primers and probes given this
fragment you hit continue
the algorithm will begin to work to
design your custom assay and once this
is complete you'll receive an email with
saying that the assay design is complete
and it will have the assay id for your
specific custom taqman assay
so i know that was a lot of content
pretty quickly
i'll review it again kind of briefly but
this time instead i'll just show you a
little bit of difference if we go back
to the thermo fisher main page again
i'll show you how a genotyping assay
would be ordered so again we go popular
taqman real-time pcr assays
and then from there you launch the
custom assay design tool
and so previously we selected order
custom gene expression assays now we're
going to order a custom genotyping assay
we can name our genotyping assay let's
just call it
fat you can paste in or type in a
nucleic acid sequence of interest
and then the only major difference for a
genotyping assay is the specific snip
location that you intend to target you
have to put that in brackets
and then a slash between
the two potential
bases or two potential snips at that
specific locus so given this fragment
pasted in here with the brackets around
these two potential snips we will be
able to order a custom genotyping assay
with one probe targeting the t sequence
here and potentially being fam labeled
the other targeting the c sequence here
and being dick labeled
and so that was a pretty
pretty quick overview of our custom
assay design tool
at the end of the presentation i'll
cover all of the resources that thermo
fisher has available for you to reach
out and get assistance with walking
through this i know it's a lot to walk
through and kind of a lot to digest in a
short period of time so by all means we
reach out to me or my colleagues within
the thermo official organization for
assistance kind of going through this
process
so now i'll jump back to the slides um
quickly
and so case study 2 should be pretty
well addressed researcher for case study
2 should have gone to the custom assay
design tool pasted in the fragment
they're interested in for their heat
shock protein mrna and should receive a
custom taqman assay targeting the mrna
for their heat shock protein
so let's jump ahead to a new scenario so
now rather than ordering either
pre-designed assays or custom taqman
assays now we want to order individual
oligos so we want to order individual
primers
that can be accomplished via
thermo-fisher through the thermofisher
website
these individual primers um you'll need
to specify the sequence you'd like
the scale of the primer purification
method that you would like the
formulation and then if you like any
five prime or three prime modifications
which is never really used for qpcr but
may be used if you're doing you know
capillary electrophoresis or some other
application um you can put five prime
and three prime modifications on the
primers
you can also order individual custom
pacman probes from thermofisher so to
order these individual probes again
you'll need to specify the sequence of
the probe that you'd like the scale
you'd like to order the quantum molecule
the reporter molecule that you'd like on
your probe as well as the format of the
probe
so to demonstrate this let's look at
case study three
and so in case study three it says a lab
is developing a molecular diagnostic
assay to detect isocitrate dehydrogenase
one so idh1 mutations in patients with
acute myeloid leukemia
the assay developers want to screen
multiple primary probe designs before
finalizing the design of their assay
they need to order individual oligos and
test different combinations of these
oligos to determine which design which
combination of primers and probes is
most sensitive and specific to the idh1
mutation that they're attempting to
identify
and so to
assist this lab in case study three
we'll jump back to the thermo fisher
website
and so we're again we're just on the
main splash page
on the thermo fisher website
um to order individual oligos again
you'll go to this button up here that
says popular
and one of the options is oligos primers
and probes
so if you select all of those primers
and probes you'll be taken to this page
from this page to order the primers what
you're going to want to select is custom
dna oligos
so if you select custom dna oligos
you now can you can order your oligos
you know in tubes or in plate format so
it sounds like the
the lab in case study three just wants
to screen multiple primer designs so i'm
sure they want small volumes i'm sure
they want them in single tube format so
we'll order these in single tube format
and then you're taken to this screen and
so from this screen the first thing
you'll be prompted to do
is
let me just briefly log back in here
so from this screen the first thing
you'll be prompted to do is to provide a
name for your oligarch so we'll just
call this idh1
you know forward primer
you know in this design number one
you know you're required to provide a
researcher name so we'll put a name
there and then you can either again you
know type in or paste in the sequence
for your oligarch
and then down here are different filters
different options for exactly what you
want the material you receive to be like
so you can choose the scale of the
primer you're ordering you know however
many nanomoles or micro moles of the
primer you'd like to order so we'll
select 15 animals
you can choose the purification you
would like use for this particular
primer so you can choose to have the
primer you know just desalted you can
have it
um cartridge purified so using reverse
phase chromatography can have hplc
purified or you can have it purified via
poly criminal prolly acrimony gel for
electrophoresis
and then also you can choose to have the
um receive the primer either dry meaning
it's going to be lyophilized in the tube
so that you reconstitute the primer when
you receive it in your lab or you can
receive the primer in solution in water
at some specific concentration of your
choosing
and so that's a pretty pretty
straightforward pretty simple approach
for ordering primers and then to order
additional primers you just hit add
another oligo
and then paste in the information or you
know enter in the information here for
your second ford primer for idh1 your
reverse primers for idh1 for however
many oligos or excuse me how many
primers you intend to order so that's
how you would order custom primers
we'll just
go back to the thermo fisher main page
again
so now in addition to those individual
primers that we want to order we also
want to order some individual probes
so again we'll go to popular
select oligos primers and probes
and from this screen here now rather
than selecting ordering custom dna
oligos we want to order custom taqman
probes
and so you can see from from this screen
you can select if you'd like to order an
mgb probe a tamra probe or a qsy probe
or you can just click this red button
which will give you the option of
ordering any of those three
and so from this screen
the first thing you'll be prompted to do
when placing the order for your custom
tacman probe is give your order a name
so it's named here idh assay development
you will be required to give your probe
a name so this would be like idh1
probe you know probe design number one
whatever naming convention or naming
nomenclature you like to use for your um
your probe
you can paste in or type in the sequence
that you like to evaluate for this
specific probe
choose the scale or the amount of the
probe you'd like to receive
choose which quencher molecule you would
like to have on the probe
and what you can notice is that
depending on the quencher molecule
chosen here
you'll have different five prime
reporter dies available for choosing so
if you select that you want an mgb nfq
quencher you see that you can order fam
vic ned or excuse me tet and ned as the
reporter die but you don't have the
ability to order abby and june if using
an nfq mgb quencher if we now transition
to this qsy quencher
now we do have the ability to order an
abbey and june probe just know that the
the quencher you choose does impact
which of the five prime dies are
available for you for that specific um
probe
and similarly to the the primers the
probe can be either received lyophilized
or dried down or can be received in
solution already reconstituted i'm
totally up to you how you would like to
receive this probe material
and similarly to with the ordering of
the primers you can hit add oligo and
it'll give you you know the room and the
ability to order multiple probes kind of
all in one i'm all in one order
and so that covers ordering
custom primers and probes as individual
ola goes via the thermo fisher website
and so now i will jump back to our
slides
and so case study three has been pretty
well addressed um this this lab this
molecular diagnostic lab
we'll be able to order the individual
primers individual probes they want to
be able to screen different assay
designs for kind of moving forward on
this idh1 project
so now let's say that that let's jump to
case study four so now let's say that
same lab they have
um kind of solidified their assay
designs they know which primers and
probe perform the best and they know
exactly what they want the primer and
probe sequences to be moving forward but
now they're transitioning you know from
like an r d environment to more of a
production style environment so they're
going to need to increase the the
throughput within their lab they may
want to make the workflow within their
lab a little more straightforward so
right now the technicians within their
lab would be adding you know ford primer
reverse primer and probe to every master
mix that's prepared maybe they would
much rather have you know a 20x taqman
assay with that specific forward primer
reverse primer and probe within it so
rather than adding three different
oligos to every master mix you have one
assay mix one custom design taqman assay
with the customer sequences in it for
ease of use in the laboratory
so that is also possible via the custom
assay design tool and i'll just read
case study 4 here for you which just
which virtually says what i would have
just described the assay developers from
case study three have decided on their
final primer improved designs they now
want to order these designs in a single
tube assay or a taqman array plate
format to simplify their workflow and
essentially to increase the throughput
within their lab
and so if i once again jump out of the
slides
and navigate back to thermo fisher's
main page
and we're actually going back to the
custom assay design tool which you've
already seen so once again i highlight
over this popular button here
select pacman real time pcr assays
and then from there
launch the custom
assay design tool
and previously when
i demonstrate when i demoed this custom
assay design tool we selected ordering
custom genotyping assays or custom gene
expression assays this is where you
would paste in a fragment and thermo
fisher would do the design work for you
but in this specific case for case study
4 where we've screened the different
primary probe designs and it's the
actual customer's design that they want
in a
custom pacman assay
you can go to this button here where it
says enter custom primer probe pairs
and so if you were to select that
you're taken to this screen
and you'll be prompted to you know enter
an assay name
similar to ordering the oligos
enter your forward primer sequence
enter your reverse primer sequence enter
your probe sequence
you can check the format again
and similarly to with the other custom
taqman assays after you've entered this
information you'll get an email sent to
you
with the assay id for your custom
designed assay and then you'll be able
to order that material using that custom
assay id
so this is the tool you would use for
entering your own primer and probe
sequences for ordering your own custom
pacman assay with your individual
designs
and so if we jump jump back to the
slides for the final time i believe
so case study 4 should be pretty well
accomplished now you can use the custom
assay design tool to generate a custom
assay design that has the customer's
primary probe designs
within it so fully customizable using
the custom asset design tool
and so next just one quick designation
that i think is important to to point
out um with ordering all these assays
whether it be an off-the-shelf assay or
a custom assay there's two different
numbers that will be needed for ordering
the assay one of which is referred to as
the part number or catalog number this
is that shell number that i showed you
that would change based on the volume of
the assay being ordered the die of the
assay being ordered and it'll be a
different part number depending on if
it's a pre-designed assay or a custom
assay so that would be the part number
or catalog number
the part number and catalog number have
nothing to do with the actual
design of the assay what species it's
targeting what transcript is targeting
information like that part number
catalog number just refers to die volume
um you know scale things like that the
assay id on the other hand that's that
alphanumeric sequence i showed you where
the prefix refers to the species of
interest so for the pdl1 assay we looked
at it was hs for homo sapien the sus the
suffix gives you some information about
the assay design so we saw a pdl1 assay
that had the m1 suffix with m1 meaning
the probe spans an exon exon junction
and then between the prefix and suffix
there was a seven or eight digit
numerical identifier um similarly for
the custom taqman assets as i mentioned
you'll receive in your email an
individual unique assay id for your
specific custom essay to be able to
place an order for either an off the
shelf assay or a custom essay you need
both the part number
as well as the assay id you need both of
those numbers
so the the four case studies that i have
spoken to thus far those were
hypothetical scenarios that were that
were kind of made up and it could apply
to you know different labs and different
regions of the
the country or the world
um the case study i'm going to highlight
now is an actual true case study so one
of our inside sales representatives um
sadia showaib
she connected with eva shinkman the
linkedin
and eva was a researcher and a phd
candidate at eastern virginia medical
school and her research was focused on
specific senescence biomarkers in mouse
embryos under stress conditions
and eva had a
a lot of institutional knowledge really
strong background and embryology
just reproductive health and in vitro
fertilization but eva was not extremely
familiar with real-time pcr and had very
little experience with real-time pcr
however to complete her phd work and
defend her dissertation there were you
know a series of qpcr experiments that
she had to complete
so sadia and even i met and discussed we
navigated thermo fisher website to see
if the senescence biomarkers that she
was interested in were present in our
catalog of assays and in fact all five
of the biomarkers she was interested in
did have pre-designed taqman assays
available for her so she was able to
order those assays in addition she
ordered a primer limited endogenous
control assay so primer limited assays
are extremely useful
if you're testing a housekeeping gene or
an endogenous control that may be in
very very high abundance so in eva's
case she chose a housekeeping gene that
wasn't high abundance so it was really
beneficial for her to be able to order
an off-the-shelf primary limited assay
i mean another challenge with eva's
research was the starting material were
embryos she had very little nucleic acid
to start with so she really needed a
simple but very sensitive and effective
approach to the workflow to complete
these experiments so she purchased our
in vitrogen sales to ct kit which
essentially has a start to finish
workflow for rt qpcr experimentation
she was able to complete the experiments
needed successfully the defend her
dissertation and graduate and finish her
work at eastern virginia medical school
and eva was able to do all of this work
without doing any assay design herself
so she totally relied on the designs
within the thermo fisher you know
pre-designed pac-man assay catalog so
she was new to qpcr was able to use
taqman chemistry and didn't have to do
any of the design work herself
and since eva has
finished her work at eastern virginia
medical school she's now working at art
lab consulting which is an ibs skills
and training center located in rocky
mountain north carolina and art lab
consulting is actually a business that
eva
both founded and serves as the president
of
and then the last thing i was hoping to
mention today during this webinar is
that when you as a customer go to
navigate our website and kind of take
this on your own and find the materials
that you need
for the success of your lab find the
tools on our website that you need to
order those materials it can be a bit of
a challenging and daunting process and i
know
i covered a lot of this content very
quickly it can be a little bit of a
dense content and just watching this
webinar one time
may not be enough to make it an
efficient process for you to go online
and order the materials so just know
that there are individuals within the
thermo official organization that you
should definitely reach out to for
assistance so we have a team of
technical sales specialists that are
located regionally they cover numerous
different products so definitely reach
out to your technical sales specialist
with any questions you may have we have
a genetic analysis sales representatives
also located regionally these are these
folks that may have sold you your
real-time pcr instruments they can also
you know support your purchase of pacman
assays they should be able to help you
navigate the website show you the
information you need to order these
taqman assays we also have a team of
field application scientists located um
you know throughout the united states
and globally i'm a member of the team of
field application scientists so
definitely reach out to your local fas
have them kind of walk you through the
website
and navigate these tools for finding the
appropriate assay for the work in your
lab and in addition to all these options
if you're ever in a situation where you
need immediate help immediate technical
support definitely take advantage of the
technical support phone number listed
there on that slide
if you choose extension 212 it will take
you through to our real-time pcr experts
and there's a really talented bright
group of individuals i'm there waiting
to take your call and help you um and
give you immediate assistance so
definitely reach out to all of these
individuals within the thermal official
organization
for navigating the website and finding
the tools that you need to make sure
you're successful in your lab
and so with that that concludes all the
content that i was hoping to share in
today's webinar and so
i believe we have time for a few
questions
thank you ben for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the live q and a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
our first question is can i receive the
primer and probe sequences
of an off-the-shelf taqman assay for
submission to a regulatory agency
so thank you for that question that's a
really good question um generally
speaking the answer would be no we
generally don't give out the sequences
of the primers and probes for our
pre-designed or the shelf taqman assays
however if this were something like
submission to a regulatory agency there
are
two options available um the first of
which would be to enter into an nba
non-disclosure agreement with thermo
fisher and if that is done you can
receive the primer and probe sequences
the other option if submitting to a
regulatory agency would be that thermo
fisher can actually submit them to the
regulatory agency for you or on your
behalf so you never see the primer and
probe sequences but the regulatory body
will see them so those would be the two
options that are you know potential
avenues for getting the primer and probe
sequences when they absolutely are
needed but as a general rule the primer
improved sequences for those off the
shelf assays are not given out
all right thank you
can off-the-shelf pacman assays and
custom taqman assays be gmp manufactured
um so the general answer there is yes
all custom taqman assays all
off-the-shelf tacman assays if needed
can be manufactured in a gmp facility
which is iso 13485
certified and is registered with the fda
um so yes that can be accomplished if
needed um one thing to just be aware of
is that if the the material is ordered
as gmp
then the time required to actually
receive the material will be longer than
if you ordered the assays as ru but to
answer the question yes all of the
tacman assays both off the shelf and
custom tacman assays can be ordered as
gmp all right
next question can thermo fisher
synthesize a control of known copy
number for use with my custom tacman
assay
so yes therma thermofisher has several
options for
either for just you know positive
controls in general or if you need a
standard for doing like an absolute
quantitation experiment um some of the
different options within thermo fisher
for ordering these controls would be you
know ordering a gene art string so gene
arc strings are synthetic double
stranded linearized dna fragments that
can be ordered you could also order a
gene art plasmid which is just what it
sounds like a plasmid with a sequence of
interest and stir inserted
um if a more you know biologically
relevant control is needed you know you
can order acrometrics controls so there
are several options within the thermo
fisher family for ordering control
material
that would align with these you know
pac-man assays
all right and it looks like we have time
for one more question
can takman assays be ordered with
reporter guys
other than fam and vic for deeper
multiplexing
so the answer to that is yes so fam is
by far the the most used reporter die
i'mma say vic is probably the second
most commonly used reporter die if you
want to do deeper multiplexing so three
or more targets
assays can be ordered with other dyes we
have a
specialty oligos group
and you would just need to email that
specialty olgos group tell them exactly
what material you want what die you
would like bound to the five prime into
your probe and specialty oligos
can accommodate your request
and so i believe the the email address
for specialty oligos is actually in in
the slides um in today's presentation
but yes um other guys other than the
family that can be ordered for these
pacman essays
all right thank you do you have any
final comments for our audience
i just think thank you to everyone in
the audience for for joining today um i
really appreciate you joining the
webinar i hope you found the webinar
informative i know there was a lot of
content covered
so please don't be shy about reaching
out to myself or others within the
thermo official organization so we can
help you you know navigate the website
you know choose between pre-designed
assays or custom assays and find the
tools that you need to ensure the
success of your lab
well thank you again ben for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you